Hãy cho chúng tâm sự báo khi tự thử vàng khúc xa, hồi bẩy giường ngày 15 tháng bẩy,
bẩy chỉ tâm báo số 2 ở vào khoảng 20 phẩy bà độ ví bắt,
một trong 15 phẩy bốn độ kinh đồng.
Sức só mạnh nhất của người tâm báo mạnh cấp 3 cấp chiến,
dật cấp 14,000 dí chuyển theo hướng tây tây bắt với túc độ từ năm đến 1 kí lồ mẽ trình dở.
Đến bẩy giường ngày 15 tháng bẩy, báo trên đủ biển viện phía đông bác biển đông
với sức só mạnh cấp 14,000 dật cấp 14 và có khả năng mạnh thêm.
Báo dí chuyển theo hướng bác với túc độ từ năm đến 1 kí lồ mẽ trình dở.
Cuộc vực chiệu an hướng là phong biển viện phía đông bác hồ vực bác biển đông
cất độ dùi gió thình tài cấp 3.
Đến bẩy giường ngày 15 tháng bẩy, báo trên phong biển tình phúc kiến,
Trung Quốc, với sức só mạnh cấp 14,000 dật cấp 12.
Báo dí chuyển theo hướng bác đông bác với túc độ 15 kí lồ mẽ trình dở.
Cuộc vực chiệu an hướng là phong biển viện phía đông bác hồ vực bác biển đông
cất độ dùi gió thình tài cấp 3.
Đến bẩy giường ngày 15 tháng bẩy, báo trên đất liền tình chết sang, Trung Quốc,
với sức só mạnh cấp 14,000 dật cấp 12.
Báo dí chuyển theo hướng bác đông bác với túc độ 15 kí lồ mẽ trình dở.
Tự bẩy mẽ hai đến chi mê sấu dơ tế theo,
báo dí chuyển theo hướng tây tây bác với túc độ khoảng 15 kí lồ mẽ trình dở
và suy yếu dần thành một vùng á thấp.
Giờ thác đồng của báo, vùng biển viện phía đông bác hồ vực bác biển đông
cộng bử báo và gió mạnh cấp 12.
Bùng gần tất báo đi qua cấp chiến cấp 15.
Dịch cấp 14, bình đồng sức dội,
sống cao từ bún đệ xong mẽ.
Tào thuyền hoạt động trong các vụ viện nói trên điều có khả năng
chữ tác động của giống.
Lúc, gió mạnh, xong lớn.